I'm here today to talk to you about a
very powerful little word one that
people will do almost anything to avoid
becoming billion dollar industries
thrive because of the fear of it and
those of us who undeniably are it a left
to navigate a relentless storm
surrounding it I'm not sure if any of
you have noticed but I'm fat
not the lowercase mutters behind my back
kind or the seemingly harmless chubby or
cuddly I'm not even the more
sophisticated voluptuous or curvaceous
kind let's not sugarcoat it
I am the capital F eighty kind of fat I
am
the elephant in the room when I walked
out on stage some of you may have been
thinking oh this is going to be
hilarious because everybody knows that
fat people are funny or you may have
been thinking where does she get her
confidence from because a confident fat
woman is almost unthinkable the
fashion-conscious members of the
audience may have been thinking how
fabulous I look in this Beth Ditto dress
thank you very much as some of you might
have thought Oh black would have been so
much more slimming you may have wondered
consciously or not if I have diabetes or
a partner or if I eat carbs after 7 p.m.
you may have worried that you ate carbs
after 7:00 p.m. last night and that you
really should renew you gym membership
these judgments are insidious they can
be directed at individuals and groups
and they can also be directed at
ourselves and this way of thinking is
known as fatphobia like any form of
systemic oppression fatphobia is deeply
rooted in complex structures like
capitalism patriarchy and racism and
that can make it really difficult to see
let alone challenge we live in a culture
where being fat is seen as being a bad
person lazy greedy unhealthy
irresponsible and morally suspect and we
tend to see thinness as being
universally good responsible successful
and in control of our appetites bodies
and lives we see these ideas again and
again in the media in public health
policy doctors offices in everyday
conversations and in our own attitudes
we may even blame fat people themselves
for the discrimination they face because
after all if we don't like it we should
just lose weight easy this anti fat bias
has become so integral so ingrained to
how we value ourselves in each other
that we rarely question why we have such
contempt for people of size and where
that disdain comes from but we must
question it because the enormous value
we place on how we look affects every
one of us and do we really want to live
in a society where people are denied
their basic humanity if they don't
subscribe to some arbitrary form of
acceptable so when I was six years old
my sister used to teach ballet to bunch
a little girls in our garage I was about
a foot taller in a foot wider than most
of the group when it came to doing our
first performance I was so excited about
wearing a pretty pink tutu
I was going to spark as the other girls
slipped easily into their lycra intial
creations not one of the tutus was big
enough to fit me I was determined not to
be excluded from the performance so I
turned to my mother and loud enough for
everyone to hear said mum I don't need a
- - I need a 4/4
thanks mom and although I didn't
recognize it at the time claiming space
for myself in that glorious 4 4 was the
first step towards becoming a radical
fat activist now I'm not saying that
this whole body love thing has been an
easy skip along a glittering path of
self-acceptance since that day in class
far from it I soon learnt that living
outside what the mainstream considers
normal can be a frustrating an isolating
place I've spent the last 20 years
unpacking and deprogramming these
messages and it's been quite the roller
coaster I've been openly laughed at
abused from passing cars and we've told
that I'm delusional I also received
smiles from strangers who recognized
what it takes to walk down the street
with a spring in your step and your head
held high and through it all that fierce
little six-year-old has stayed with me
and she has helped me stand before you
today as an unapologetic fat person a
person that simply refuses to subscribe
to the dominant narrative about how I
should move through the world in this
body of mine
and I'm not alone I am part of an
international community of people who
choose to rather than passively
accepting that our bodies are and
probably always will be big we actively
choose to flourish in these bodies as
they are today people who honor our
strengths and work with not against our
perceived limitations people who value
health is something much more holistic
than a number on an outdated BMI chart
instead we value mental health
self-worth and how we feel in our bodies
as vital aspects to our overall
well-being people who refuse to believe
that living in these fat bodies is a
barrier to anything really there are
doctors academics and bloggers who have
written countless volumes on the many
facets of this complex subject there are
fact in Easter's here acclaim their
bodies and their beauty by wearing fat
Keeney's and crop tops exposing the
flesh that we're all taught to hide
there are fat athletes who run marathons
teach yoga or do kickboxing all done
with the middle finger firmly held up to
the status quo and these people have
taught me that radical body politics is
the antidote to our body shaming culture
but to be clear I'm not saying that
people shouldn't change their bodies if
that's what they want to do reclaiming
yourself can be one of the most gorgeous
acts of self-love and can look like a
million different things from hairstyles
tattoos to body contouring to hormones
to surgery and yes even weight loss it's
simple it's your body and you decide
what's best to do with it
my way of engaging in activism is by
doing all the things that we fatties
aren't supposed to do and there's a lot
of them inviting other people to join me
and then making art about it the common
thread through most of this work has
been reclaiming space
that are often prohibitive to bigger
bodies from the catwalk to club shows
from public swimming pools two prominent
dance stages and reclaiming spaces on
mass is not only a powerful artistic
statement but a radical community
building approach this was so true of
aqua Porco the FATF M synchronized swim
team I started with a group of friends
in Sydney the impact of seeing a bunch
of defiant fat women in Flowery swimming
caps and bathers throwing their legs in
the air without a care should not be
underestimated
throughout my career I have learned that
fat bodies are inherently political and
unapologetic fat bodies can blow
people's minds when director Kate
champion of acclaimed dance theater
company force-majeure asked me to be the
artistic associate on a work featuring
all fat dances I literally jumped at the
opportunity and I mean literally nothing
to lose is a work made in collaboration
with performance of size who drew from
their lived experiences to create a work
as varied and authentic as we all are
and it was as far from ballet as you
could imagine the very idea of a fat
dance work by such a prestigious company
was to put it mildly controversial
because nothing like it had ever been
done on mainstream dance stages before
anywhere in the world people were
skeptical
what do you mean fat dancers like size
10 size 12 kind of fat where do they do
their dance training are they going to
have the stamina for a full-length
production but despite the skepticism
nothing to lose became a sellout hit of
Sydney festival we received rave reviews
toured won awards and we're written
about in over 27 languages these
incredible images of our cast were seen
worldwide I've lost count of how many
times people of all sizes have told me
that the show has changed their lives
how it helped them shift their
relationship to their own and other
people's bodies and how it made them
confront their own bias but of course
work that pushes people's buttons is not
without its detractors I have been told
that I'm glorifying obesity I have
received violent death threats and abuse
daring to make work that centers fat
people's bodies and lives and treats us
as worthwhile human beings with valuable
stories to tell I've even been called
the ISIS of the obesity epidemic a
comment so absurd that it is funny but
it also speaks to the panic the literal
terror that the fear of fat can evoke it
is this fear that's feeding the diet
industry which is keeping so many of us
from making peace with our own bodies
for waiting to be the after photo before
we truly start to live our lives because
the real elephant in the room here is
fat phobia fat activism refuses to
indulge this fear by advocating for
self-determination and respect for all
of us
we can shift society's reluctance to
embrace diversity and start to celebrate
the myriad of ways there are to have a
body thank you